okay it's upside down I'm sorry I just
can't get enough of this book I know
it's amazing
name drop name isn't that fun look at my
things look this is the actual jacket I
wear on the cover and I love it thank
you
you look amazing and this it is
incredible what made you want to do this
well you know I have loved pop culture
since I was just like growing up in a
little farm town I've been obsessed with
it and if you can believe it it's almost
20 years I've been on TV almost two
decades and I really feel like I won the
golden ticket as a superfan because I I
went from my farm town to Hollywood and
I I've been able to go into the parties
go past the velvet rope and meet the
people who have always wanted to meet so
I feel an obligation to write a book
like this for the superfans because it's
as good as you always thought it would
be yes except for a few times when
somebody breaks your heart okay okay we
have so much in it but I think that's
why people love you so much it's because
you know when you were on the Jay Leno
Show we were rooting for you and
everyone you just you jumped into
everyone's hearts and you've stayed
there which is really amazing which is
why we're excited about this book so are
you known to name-drop well I I start
the book by saying that name-dropping is
tacky I know that my best friend going
with Paltrow taught me that so so of
course it's tongue-in-cheek it is so
tacky to name-drop but I I kind of just
lean into it you know I feel like one of
us there's us and there's them I'm one
of us and so I feel like it's okay for
us to have this kind of conversation
when I'm out and about at happy hour
people come up to me all the time and
they want to know who's nice who's not
nice who smells the best whose hair is
real and so this is really the combo
that I'm having with people when I'm out
in the real world I love that you have a
Barbara Walters story because listen
I've been in the same room with her as
well and you just feel that energy it is
a thing what will we be hearing about in
that book well most of the times when I
met people that I love they've been
better than I ever could have dreamt but
Barbara
was not
I love her and I still love her I mean I
even wrote a paper on her in college did
you really I did because I looked at
this broadcaster with a unique voice and
hello I sort of related you know and
she's always been like an icon of mine
and when I met her the first time we did
hit it off I was a guest on the view and
we she liked me so much she invited me
back amazing it took co-host this is
back in like 2005 or something and so
they scheduled it for a month later I'm
on cloud nine my best friend is Barbara
Walters right and when I showed up she
said who are you and why are you here
and so I tried to get her on my side by
the way Barbara was sharp his attack
bang on you know she's the best in the
business she was running the view like a
finely tuned machine she just was not
kind because I did ask her trying to get
her on my side I said as they're
counting us down live one of you guys do
you have any last minute words of advice
for me and she says I'd like to tell you
to go out and be yourself but I hope you
won't and you died inside and walked out
I shrivel do and then they're like three
to go and we're on live TV and it just
got worse from there and it wasn't great
you know and but it made me a better
broadcaster it does because you have to
go you have to go they don't you don't
care if behind the scenes is a mess you
want a good show
and so I had to go out there and deliver
for the audience and now because of
Barbara Walters nothing ruffles my
feathers that's amazing well season you
thank you for that and then you know I
almost I almost was the first male
co-host on the view I know that and you
go into that in the book right I do I
love that story yeah they told me I had
was auditioning I didn't even know I was
auditioning this is like 10 years after
the first Barbara Walters encounter I
keep going back to co-host you know I
didn't even really know I was
auditioning and then they pull me into a
room and they said sherry and Jenny and
Whoopi and I have talked and Bill Getty
the executor producer we want you so get
ready to move to back we move to New
York and so I go on the plane and what
do you do when you're on the plane and
you're rich because you're coast of the
Vieux Carre the cocktail well duh
and then but you splurge for Wi-Fi right
as a bike I get a for $22 I got this I'm
now coast of you and when I did I turned
on you know the gossip sites and the
headline on TMZ was view firing massacre
and everybody who had just told me I was
hired unison I'm 30,000 feet in the air
yes now fired and you like cancel the
Wi-Fi can't cancel it
can I call Amex can I get my money back
because it all vanished at 30,000 feet
it just disappeared such a good story
that's small and then you've got Lady
Gaga who everyone just you know she's
everything everyone's captivated by her
I I mean love Lady gaga I feel like in a
weird way we have to be from the same
planet because look what I'm wearing but
we had never met we did have a weird
interaction at the Golden Globes once
when I was covering it for EE and I was
I was covering the Golden Globes I was
up on the riser ya know and I contact
with her and she looked at me and we
just kind of held this eye contact like
too long what what does that mean and
then season 9 of RuPaul's Drag Race I
didn't know until you know ten seconds
before she was the guest judge and when
she walks out on stage Gaga says hi Daru
hi to Michelle had a carson and then she
says Ross I need to talk to you and what
Lady Gaga proceeds to tell me is the
greatest Lady Gaga story of all time
what do you want to know what she said
to me yes what she said to me was what
she said to me is we're going to break
you'll hear the answer right after this
it's not like it was a natural thing to
do but no okay what happened so go what
she said to me is in this new book named
drop and you're gonna do that and that's
why I said go to break but it's worth it
and it's the first chapter in here and
you can also make yourself a star fruit
martini is born well that's the thing
you've got Raza peas in here that match
with your celebrity stories yes because
this book feels like you and I are at
happy hour right so I wanted to give
them happy hour right now girl it feels
like we're at happy hour together when
you read this book so I wanted to make
sure you had all the tools you needed so
for every chapter like for the Celine
Dion chapter there's my artichoke heart
will go on for for uh give me a bit
first
Faye Dunaway who was in Mommy Dearest
mhm you can make my recipe for edamame
Dearest and it just gets dumber and
dumber but I also understand that there
is a story that you left out of this
book that after we all buy it you might
put it in the next book which is the
Sarah Ferguson so then I say can you its
et Canada you we we warm the cockles of
your heart for that I do I didn't put
this in there it's funny I didn't
remember the story until after I wrote
the book and I thought why don't you put
that in there okay girl you're gonna get
it look a bit like just did like mmm so
I was in London for The Tonight Show
way back in probably 2003 okay and she
was doing some like weird show I don't
know what it was I still don't know what
it was but they said she agreed to be
interviewed by you and I was like oh my
god that's probably a bad idea what so
we went to Notting Hill no one ever has
heard this story before you're the only
person affinity where we go to Notting
Hill
which is at part of London and she shows
up with this guy and my producers like
who's the guy Duchess who is that and
she goes you know he was someone on a
dating show there who I think maybe I
don't know let I don't know if she was
hooking up with him but I don't know why
were together okay and it's not through
and she's like well he's going to be in
the shop with us my producer is like no
one knows who he is like we we just want
you you know what
no she's like he's on a show here we're
like well we don't care it like this is
about you guys and she's like I'm not
doing it unless you put him in the shot
I promised him he'd be in it and my
producers like I don't know what to do
and she goes Ross can you come with me
and so I'm 22 23 I'm like okay we walk
her in the corner she goes listen to me
I did this as a favor to Jeff sucker you
will not me over you got me and I was
like I love to you so he walked out us
they gave me into my producers I go we
are putting him in shop just great so we
had to like they pretended that he was
part of it and then they just pushed
into it to shop and he just stood there
silently and we know we never showed him
but she pulled me aside and like already
finger in your nose finger in my face
like swearing at me
twenty-two-year-old like I had any power
whatever you want easy no sweating -
uh-huh
keep it all so in this book on top of
the celebrity stories you also get very
personal about your family and then your
parents why was that important for you
to put it in there well you know I am
always smiling and always happy to be
there and always having a really good
time but my life is full of ups and
downs just like everybody else is you
know my father passed away when I was
too young I've gone I went to a break up
well write in this book and while
experiencing some of the stuff in this
book
my mom has battled health issues and
still does and so there are times like
when my dad was dying I was hosting New
Year's Eve in Times Square and it was
really tough I got the news that he had
like a week left as I was about to go go
live and I didn't want to do it and I
felt like I was faking it and it felt so
false you know but then by the end of
doing it in the center of all these
people celebrating life they made me
almost come back to life yeah a little
bit and then I ran into on the way home
from that I went into a and Bancroft I
didn't know who she was her at the time
but she walked on the plane
there she walked by and she said young
man you made me laugh last night and I
really needed that
you keep doing what you do and then
within months they were both gone they
were both gone my dad and her and it
gave me just a little perspective you
know and I I wanted to put that in here
so people didn't think it was just fluff
that it was also some lessons because
these people are real and that's what
you learn when you get to get to know
them